Michael's with us an Alabama hey Michael
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Dave
thanks for taking Nicole my pleasure how
can I help
well I have a question about a mammoth
amount of student loans that I have that
are continuing to grow at a break at a
ridiculous rate how big is the mammoth
200,000 good lord are you a doctor or
lawyer I'm a doctor but not the kind
that you want
I'm a doctor of ministry so you've got
an m.div for 200k no I'd never lose the
d.min it's the lose the middle and how
eyes aren't a demon so okay so here's
where I'm at I'm baby step two and I
don't make a whole lot of money because
I'm in ministry but so here is my
question I know the stories of the
public loans forgiveness program I know
how in general it hasn't worked here's
the big problem I can't afford the
minimum payment right now my minimum
payment based on the income is zero
anyway because I've got kids and other
stuff so while I'm making headway and
paying this stuff off here's what I was
thinking and I wanted your thoughts so
when I get to that look because I'm
planning on having everything my car and
all the fun stuff paid off somewhere
around April may possibly faster
depending on some other things but when
I get to this I thought well I can't
make the minimum payment anyways a
minimum payments 1500 and if I'd paid
that how much anything other than ours
you know garden how much are you paying
on these other dads
the car is 267 dollars and I know much
are you petting harder to pay it off by
April so in February I literally was a
side-job volleyball and that gets me
roughly an extra $350 a week so how much
do you owe on your car about $6,000 and
how are you paying that off by April
some of its going to be tax returns some
it's going to be these volleyball money
and what does your household income I
make thirty three thousand a year and
then some of the tops of my income so
what Mike has are you usually you've
made choices that don't allow you to
stay in this career well I thought about
that so 88% of pastors in North America
are by vocational and you're getting
ready to be I understand that so that's
the other side of the time I do I plan
on working on something else too but
here's my question with and that's what
I was thinking
if I continued with this debt
forgiveness program that probably won't
work
it is know we need three people have
gotten it out of thirty thousand it's
not even logical to discuss well what I
was trying to ask was when I get to that
person if I served up with a record
because if they did forgive it it still
becomes taxable income so I had a tax
liability bit and then if they didn't
forgive it a three whatever I said that
it and still tackled it that way I was
kind of warming your ideas and option
yeah I wouldn't even have that in my
discussion because it's just not
relevant I mean you got better chance of
going to Vegas and winning money
hour-by-hour buying a lotto ticket the
ratios are so bad on this actually
working and so this is a situation where
you have a tremendous student loan debt
and you've got to make some adjustments
to your career path so that your income
can go up while you do ministry I'm not
suggesting God didn't call you to the
ministry I'm suggesting that the
borrower's slave to the lender and it's
tough to serve two masters and then I
got you that's where you are so you've
got to adjust some things and you've got
to get your income up and throw it all
at these student loans
and let all the young pastors know not
to go $200,000 in debt to get a
doctorate in ministry to make $33,000 a
year God does not call you to do that
and called you the ministry maybe but
didn't call you to do that so I'm so
sorry you're in this situation it's
heartbreaking I'm so sorry